[Music]
my daughter is just as obsessed with
hair and makeup and entertainment as I
she's all into it like all the
Rhinestone brushes she's helped me along
the way so it's good to have an opinion
from a six-year-old we all need a little
you do you love mommy's product
everything maxwell's got the total
hookup when it comes to getting glam in
addition to her fashion empire her mom
was launching a new cosmetics line
beauty fiend but it's not just the
makeup that keeps Jessica feeling sexy
do you feel sexier than ever because you
look amazing and by the way your man
looks amazing today here he keeps me hot
I have to say like such an amazing
father that it makes me want to stay
young I'm like how can you be so active
does that make you think like okay we're
good on the family for a while we're
chilling like oh yeah we are chilling I
mean we're very happy and we know how to
make babies very well but we got the
little one here yeah Jessica was at
beautycon in Los Angeles
the annual cosmetics convention is where
we caught up with another famous mom and
yep Drew's two girls love her flower
beauty line to my daughter Frankie was
drawing black eyebrows all the way
across like Priss in Blade Runner and
olive had beads and little dots
everywhere and she's just so artistic
about it and I had such pride even
though she's a makeup mogul Drew's not
afraid to bare all posting makeup free
pics like this with her bestie Cameron
Diaz something else the single mom is
just as honest about her dating life I
know you send the passenger on the apps
do you still do the apps what do you
know I got off it was fun to try though
just still single you know
did friends set you up all the time no
none of my friends ever set me up where
is the friend setting people up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]